[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome
to the quickstart
for Cloud Speech-to-Text,
which converts speech into text
using Google's AI technologies.
In this video, we
walk through how
to convert an audio file to
text using the REST interface
and the cURL command.
To get started with
Cloud Speech-to-Text,
you need a Google Cloud project.
You can use an existing
project or set up
a new one in the
Google Cloud Console
at console.cloud.google.com.
Visit the APIs & Services
section of the Console
and enable the
Cloud Speech-to-Text
API for your project.
Next, you need to set
up authentication.
In the APIs & Services
section, click on Credentials.
Create a new service account
and download the private key
as JSON.
You can use these credentials
to access Google Cloud APIs.
So make sure to keep this file
secure and out of your code
and public repositories.
To securely access the
credentials from your project,
go to your terminal and
set an environment variable
to the path of your JSON file.
If you don't yet
have the Google Cloud
SDK installed on your machine,
then install and initialize it.
Instructions are linked below.
Create a new JSON request
file, add the following text,
and save it as a
sync-request.json plaintext
file.
This JSON snippet indicates
that the audio file
has a FLAC encoding format, a
sample rate of 16,000 hertz,
and is stored in a
Google Cloud Storage
bucket at the given URI.
Next, use cURL to make a request
to the speech.googleapis.com
endpoint.
This cURL command specifies
sync-request.json as the file
name of the JSON request
you just created.
Run the cURL command,
and you should
see the following response.
Here, we can see the transcribed
text as well as a confidence
value that estimates how likely
it is that the transcription is
accurate.
And that's it.
You now know how to make a call
to the Cloud Speech-to-Text
API using a cURL command.
Make sure to check out the rest
of our Cloud Speech-to-Text
documentation at
cloud.google.com/speech
to text/docs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]